after endless debates about ownership
nigeria finally got back what was stolen
more than a century ago the first two
bronzes of more than one thousand taken
from the former kingdom of benin
including one showing the head of the
king were handed over at a ceremony at
the german foreign ministry and will
soon be on their way back home
this is a story of european colonialism
we should not forget that germany played
an active role
in this chapter of history
today
more than
120 years later
we state clearly
the head of a king
belongs to the people of nigeria the
thousands of artwork stolen from the
kingdom became a symbol of colonial
injustice when british soldiers looted
the palace in 1897 benin was one of the
most powerful kingdoms on the african
continent
for decades the great great
granddaughter of the king had campaigned
for their return
as a member of the royal family i really
feel very happy that this is happening
it's restoring
dignity and pride
in the culture that i was raised in sad
that is coming
several decades after
but i think that it's important that
that historical injustice is addressed
at this time yeah while germany did not
load the art directly more than a
thousand pieces were bought after being
taken by the british on display until
recently in museums all over the country
while the ownership of the bedin bronzes
has now finally be handed over the
german public will still be able to see
some of them at an exhibition here at
the humble forum soon germany will
continue to take care of the artworks
and will only physically return them at
the request of
nigeria while other european countries
have returned some looted artifacts to
african nations this handover by germany
to nigeria is the largest so far other
countries in the world
will
actually take a cue from germany because
it's a matter of time
they will have to return all student
artifacts to their place of origin
nigeria is building a museum to house
the returning benin bronzes so nigerians
finally do not have to travel to europe
to admire and study their own history
step faster al jazeera in berlin